[Música]
si yo tengo estos zapatos que son los
que más quiero los los entrañables los
de toda la vida con los que está con
ellos todos los días y de repente por el
uso constante tengo que cambiarles la
suela de la cambio y después resulta que
después de un tiempo tengo que cambiarle
la capellada el taco y hasta los
cordones
se podría decir que tengo otro zapato o
es el mismo
de eso se trata la reinvención del
maravilloso arte de ser otro siendo el
mismo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
escuchar la cosa ya dije te gustó la
metáfora los zapatos
17 minutos
y este
hola mi nombre es laura cali tengo 49
años casi medio siglo che bueno
evidentemente no soy un zapato pero
bueno he caminado bastante bastante en
esto del mundo del arte bueno soy
artista me costó mucho decidirme artista
yo soy
actriz soy maestra de danza tengo su
profesora de yoga
es buena tengo una hija dos gatas una
perra un patio con plantas tengo un
compañero tengo amigas amigos tengo
muchas certezas tengo muchas dudas tengo
miedos
pero también tengo danza tengo teatro y
tengo la frenética ilusión de que todo
es posible
yo comencé con esto muy chiquita tenía
18 años más o menos y la pucha habría
cambiado de zapato tengo casi 50
imagínate en esto de creer que que el
arte es imprescindible de que yo siempre
me gusta a mí me gusta referirme al arte
al teatro como aquella cosa que nos va a
redimir que nos va a sanar que nos va a
sacar de la mediocridad que nos va a
hacer modificar algo dentro que es
imprescindible para nuestras vidas
a propósito había una frase de eugène
ionesco la tenemos en no no tenemos por
los brazos del sueño dijo que decía si
para algo sirve teatro es para darnos
cuenta de que no sirve para nada
sí pero es absolutamente imprescindible
que exista si será no y esto el arte del
teatro de la danza es estar todo el
tiempo como en constante renovación en
constante reinvención es maravilloso es
algo así como como nuestro cuerpo humano
nosotros tenemos células que se mueren
células que se regeneran aunque nosotros
nos cueste mucho percibir nos de esa
manera y ver que esta estructura parece
que es permanente pero no no lo es esto
se va regenerando se va cambiando todo
el tiempo se va reinventando y esto me
enteré hace poquito quiere decir que más
o menos en un lapso de 10 años 10 años y
no más tenemos todas las células
diferentes o sea que quiere decir estos
somos otros o somos los mismos
nos reinventamos es maravilloso
maravilloso maravilloso bueno pero para
saber entonces qué es la reinvención a
mí me gusta que primero preguntarle al
diccionario qué es la invención y ahora
sí espero quedaría mi compañero tenga
esa invención creación diseño producción
de alguna cosa nueva que antes no
existía bien dice historia o creación
generalmente artística imaginaria o
ficticia
es teatro
este ataque es maravilloso esto es lo
que nos pasa esto es teatro el teatro
reúne todas todas todas esas
características más una
y es que teatro es efímero hoy lo
hablábamos en el almuerzo del bar el
teatro es la cosa más efímera del mundo
está ahora y no está más o puedes ver
una película diez veces quince veces la
película es la misma pero el teatro no
puedes escuchar un disco
disco dije que tenía 50 años escuchando
discos no sé pero bueno la música
grabada es siempre la misma sin embargo
el teatro no requiere de una actriz un
actor y un público una sola persona ya
basta para que se dé esa cosa y que la
representación no se repita no haya dos
representaciones iguales esto es
maravilloso realmente maravilloso bueno
y así vamos los artistas tratando de
reinventarnos todo el tiempo tratando de
encontrar de buscar ese vértigo
maravilloso que es como es un vértigo
pero este fatal esto porque es como
todas las veces encontrarse con una hoja
en blanco con un escenario vacío con un
círculo rojo
de verdad de verdad que a veces es muy
difícil comenzar con eso que hacemos yo
he llegado a sentir en el cuerpo y esto
créanme que es verdad
la sensación espantosa de no tener voz
de sentir como clavos en la garganta
dice que sí porque aguas también te paso
de clavos en la garganta y que no te
salgan las palabras de tener los brazos
así que no sabes dónde miércoles meter
lo que tienes no sabes qué hacer con las
maneras que hago me rasco me meto es
manera bolsillo me tocó que que hay algo
bueno hay de a poco y aquí entra el yoga
de a poco como si volvieran los signos
vitales a un cuerpo después de un
desmayo de poquito respiras y respiras y
empieza a salir la voz y empiezan a
salir los movimientos y todo se vuelve a
inventar
[Música]
no
hola mi nombre es norma leyes de puig y
pires para los que no me conocen bueno
yo voy a ser su guía turística en 3.0 en
este recorrido turístico fueron
incontables queridos pasajeros
estamos en el nuevísimo rebozado sin
pastor ahora actualmente llamado de
compra como llaman todos punto complejo
móvil complejo que ustedes saben a que
debe su nombre este complejo a don
alfredo
eusebio bobby un eximio músico santo 0
que fue el primero el primer hito en
llevar el tango a europa incluso antes
antes que gardel y junto con su esposa
flora así de espectáculos de varieté hay
en la calle un poquito más hacia arriba
y en calle 18 y montevideo cerraban todo
con bolsas de arpillera y había 100
espectáculos de magia de varieté una
belleza me encanta que es un placer para
mí ser su guía turística esta noche ese
personaje es normal leyes normas leyes
es un personaje que surgió hace un
montón de años los que son de paysandú
probablemente alguna vez hayan ido a un
bus turístico yo pertenezco a la
compañía imagina teatro con mis amigos
todos los años en la semana santa de la
cerveza de turismo hacemos hacemos el
bus turístico es un recorrido a bordo de
un ómnibus que va recorriendo lugares de
paysandú y vamos cambiando todos los
años la temática todos los años vamos
buscando personajes nuevos vamos
buscando músicas nuevas anécdotas nuevas
cosas para reinventar pero el personaje
de normales es el que se mantiene en
norma leyes es un personaje cándido a la
que le van pasando algunas cosas y que
bueno tiene que siempre buscar cómo
salvar esos obstáculos se van
encontrando cuando con músicos con
cómicos con un montón de cosas siempre
en la búsqueda de revalorizar el
patrimonio tangente y también lo
inteligente que tiene nuestra ciudad que
tiene muchos personajes riquísimos que
tiene mucha música riquísima que tiene
muchos deportistas que tiene de todo
paysandú es una belleza y bueno
casualmente el bus turístico surgió allá
por el año 2007
por una reinvención resulta que antes se
hacía un recorrido turístico formal
donde había una guía que iba relatando
los lugares de pasando la gente se moría
de aburrimiento entonces claro nos
dijeron y chistes porque no nos hacen
una intervención como quien te vengan
con personajes para darle un poquito de
de humor que es igual entonces
redoblamos la apuesta y dijimos no nos
vamos a hacer intervenciones vamos a
nosotros agarrar la posta y vamos a
hacer nosotros el recorrido turístico y
así surgió ese recorrido que hacemos con
actores arriba de anónimos con músicos
con un montón de cosas y realmente nos
ha dado esa satisfacción enorme enorme y
maravillosa de poder estar acá cerquita
con la gente hasta nos sentamos en la
falda de la gente y la voz es
maravilloso el patrimonio de los
sanduceros que divino pone me los tramos
y canales
[Música]
érase que se era
érase una vez
hubo un niño con los ojos más azules del
mundo este niño saltó de casa el rancho
de escuela en casa de delantal en hacha
hasta por fin poder encontrarse con el
amor de su padre pero esta historia se
las voy a poder contar de la única
manera que sé es como me la contaron a
mí
y hablaban ruso mi papá murió hace cinco
años y me dejó un legado importantísimo
antes de morir contaba reiteradamente
unas historias de su niñez de su
infancia y yo soy la única hija entonces
dije la fe se muere en mi papá y se
mueren estas historias entonces esto no
se puede ir con él entonces una vez más
agarre la apuesta e inventé reinvente
esas historias las pasamos por un
cernidor le dimos forma escrita rellene
los huecos con la actuación y con danza
los becos que iban dejando su memoria ya
debilitada y bueno ahí surgió matrioska
matrioskas un espectáculo unipersonal
que cuenta las historias de ese niño que
preocupa para que se habrá pasado
periplos y quedó huérfano a los cinco
años y lo regalaron pero no una vez me
regalaron cinco veces y basti casa en
casa de cama en cama de mesa en mesa
y entonces yo hoy también agradezco eso
en esa cosa que se hereda eso que si de
alguien heredé la garra la convicción y
las ganas de hacer cosas sin rencor
fue mi papá así que bueno matrioska son
personas que venimos haciendo hace años
también con esa cosa de sanación de eso
que tiene el teatro que hablaba hoy de
que las células feas se van y que las
nuevas están y que late mucho mucho
mucho mucho otra música
[Música]
i
tú
todo se mueve todo tiene movimiento y
nada puede parar de moverse se mueven
los piojos en las cabezas de los nenes
se mueven las pelotas en los jugadores
de fútbol en las patitas se mueven las
cortinas de la escuela se mueven también
las sábanas de la abuela colgadas en el
alambre todo se mueve y nada puede parar
de moverse así como matilde es matilde
tampoco puede parar de moverse
matilde quédate quieta
muster fortín de quedate quieta si las
voces van cambiando pero la sentencia de
siempre la misma
matilde quedate quieta y ella lo intenta
juro que lo intenta pero hay algo muy
fuerte en su interior algo que la lleva
a una y otra y otra y otra y otra vez al
movimiento pero entiendo a la gente
grande porque cuando estás adentro de la
panza de tu mamá y te movés un poquito
la gente agarra y dice hay en este
veranito que debe estar y cuando naces
creces un poquito y no paras de moverte
y la gente dice oh los anillos de
vitoria mira cómo se mueve
bueno eso más o menos le es de paso le
pasó a una gran coreógrafa que hoy en
día es muy exitosa a propósito esta obra
que se llamó saque a punta y compás que
fue una obra de teatro danza una obra
para niños también fue inspirada
casualmente en una charla ted la charla
de ken robinson etapas que la vieron la
charla que decía que la escuela mataba
la creatividad y bueno entonces en
contra de los diagnósticos fáciles en
contra de los diagnósticos que dicen el
niño se mueve y no puede aprender
vimos esa charla de ken robinson que
contaba la historia de gillian link que
hoy es la coreógrafa nada más y nada
menos de cats la coreógrafa del fantasma
de la ópera' que tiene años años en
cartel cuando julian quiere una visita
chiquita y no paraba de moverse y no
paraba de bailar
no aprendía en la escuela la mamá muy
preocupada la llevó al psicólogo y
entonces le dijo ay doctor yo no sé qué
pasa mi hija en inglés mi hija
no para de moverse mi hija no no sé qué
hacer está enferma entonces el doctor
muy pillo dejó a gillian adentro del
consultorio del otro lado se fueron la
vida por a través del vidrio le pusieron
la radio y chiles las empezó a bailar
como loca y bailaba y bailaba y bailaba
y bailaba
y le dijo el médico vio señora suiza no
está enferma su hija es una bailarina es
un artista y bueno y eso también es
reinventar reinventar las conductas
reinventar las sentencias eso para nada
y bueno a ver eso soy yo
también dando clases en mi salón de
danza por acá de unas cuantas ex alumnas
divinas
y eso también requiere de una
reinvención constante con niñas de 3 4 o
5 años en estos tiempos que estamos tan
bombardeados con cuánta pantalla hay en
tener la posibilidad de tener una clase
de 45 minutos de una hora en la que nos
podemos ver que nos podemos tocar que
nos podemos mirar a los ojos que nos
podemos abrazar que podemos conversar
y de yapa aprender es maravilloso es yo
diría que es no es un desafío es como
que haber como un un acto de resistencia
es eso es como una reinvención constante
y me encanta por supuesto y bueno y a
eso iba no a veces no podemos cambiar
las cosas pero decía tenemos ahí la
frase dubatti porque ese no me la puede
aprender de memoria entonces les voy a
contar dice si bien no podemos cambiar
el sistema porque las condiciones no
están dadas lo que sí podemos hacer es
nuclear nos en espacios micro políticos
para generar subjetividades alternativas
como esto como acá
para terminar les quiero dejar una
anécdota que me contó una amiga anita
una amiga que vive en libertad que tiene
un tío el viejo niño viejo es tú para
niño una vez le hicieron una entrevista
y le preguntaron a ver señor dígame qué
es para usted la política y no yo dijo
sin dejar de mirarla el escote la
entrevistadora dijo depende mi hija
depende de qué bueno depende de la hora
del día depende del día del mes
depende del mes del año del año del
milenio como como haber puede explicarse
mejor sí
al amanecer al principio del día la
política es algo así como el arte de lo
posible
cuando ya va mediando el día o el mes o
el año o el milenio la política madura
un poquito y se transforma
en hacer posible lo necesario
y cuando ya cae la noche cuando ya
promedia el año el milenio era la frase
que usaba el viejo cuando el búho
abre sus ojos en la noche la política ya
se cae de madura
y hace necesario lo posible
y siempre me gustó esta frase porque si
nosotros nos colamos eso no de la
política a lo que nosotros hacemos con
mucha pasión
que es lanzar que es actuar que es
comunicarnos esta frase se transforma
más que nada en un desafío y hoy acaba
mi imagen será petición ojalá ojalá que
podamos todos llegar al principio del
día y hacer que todo sea posible gracias
para ti no me voy a poner a bailar
porque hable tanto el zapato que al
final el desacato gracia bueno hay voy a
y voy a ver porque me encanta esto
porque yo soy como un híbrido viste yo
soy de descendencia rusa pero tengo el
baile flamenco cualquier cosa por tratos
todo bien porque me encanta para para
para
[Música]
hablando
e
[Aplausos]
yo no
desde bolsas
[Música]
ah
a mí
[Música]
chau chau chau
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah